i became terrified of public speaking
and uh
i just couldn't do it we don't love this
product but we think others will love it
and you know that's not really how it
works if you don't love it
don't expect others will either your
relationship with time is such a key
component
of your life because when you get caught
in a routine
time goes so quickly wanna be happy
build a life not just a business
i believe a life it's evan carmichael
and this channel was created to help you
overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn
how billionaires think to get some
success advice from the top
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with lesson
number one learn how to communicate with
warren buffett
i was terrified for example both in high
school
and college i don't know when it started
but i became terrified of public
speaking
and uh i just couldn't do it i mean i
and so i arranged all of my classes so i
never had to
do any public speaking and i got to
colombia
and i saw an ad in the paper uh for dale
carnegie course
and i went down it was somewhere in the
mid-40s and i gave the guy a check for a
hundred dollars and i went back and
stopped payment i lost my nerve
and then i came out i got out of
columbia actually when i was
20 and i came out to start selling
securities in omaha
and i realized i had to get up and be
able to get up in front of me i couldn't
go through life this way
so i saw an ad again in the uh local
paper that there was a dale carnegie
course being given
i went down and i gave the fellow 100 in
cash and
i became associated with 30 other people
in the class we couldn't stand up in
front of a group and say our own name i
mean it was we were it was pathetic
but that class changed my life in a big
way
as a matter of fact they used to give a
pencil every week for whoever did the
most with what they learned the previous
week
and during that class i proposed to my
wife and she accepted and i won the
pencil that week
so it it's important i mean there's
certain you've got to be able to
communicate in life
and it's enormously important and
probably the schools
to some extent under emphasize that i
mean you get started going for an mba
and people think it's kind of beneath
them to teach
about communication but if you if you
can't
communicate if you can't talk to other
people and get across your ideas or
write you know
you know you you're giving up your
potential and uh you know
anybody that's got a career potential of
x i i guarantee it'll be 150
of x if they uh if they really learn how
to communicate well so that was
that was a big a part of really
succeeding in my career
lesson number two have a relentless
determination with oprah winfrey
my television career began unexpectedly
uh as you heard this morning i was in
the miss fire prevention contest
that was when i was 16 years old in
nashville tennessee
and you had the requirement of having to
have red hair
in order to win up until the year that i
entered
so they were doing the question and
answer period because i knew i wasn't
going to win in the swimsuit competition
so during the question and answer period
the question
came why young lady what would you like
to be when you grow up
and by the time they got to me all the
good answers were gone
so i had seen barbara walters on the
today show that morning so i answered
i would like to be a journalist i would
like to
tell other people's stories in a way
that makes a difference
in their lives and the world and as
those words were coming out of my mouth
i went
whoa this is pretty good
i would like to be a journalist i want
to make a difference
well i was on television by the time i
was 19 years old
and in 1986 i launched my own television
show
with a relentless determination to
succeed at first
i was nervous about the competition and
then
i became my own competition raising the
bar
every year pushing pushing pushing
myself as hard as i knew
sound familiar to anybody here
eventually
we did make it to the top and we stayed
there for
25 years
[Applause]
the oprah winfrey show was number one in
our time slot for 21 years and i have to
tell you i became
pretty comfortable with that level of
success
lesson number three try hard with elon
musk
you hi you look for innovative people
when you hire them is it something that
that is is
pretty easy easily learnable or is there
some inequality
in the people that uh succeed i think it
is learnable
i mean step number one would be try
and have you tried and if have you tried
hard
and you haven't tried hard try hard
i think it is learnable um
it's not some mysterious thing it's just
basically just be like
an absolute perfectionist about the
product that you make the service that's
provided
um seek negative feedback from all
quarters uh you know
from customers from from people who
aren't customers like hey okay what can
we make this how do we make this better
um
and you know i think that's it
it's absolutely learnable and and and
and just
if you find yourself spending a lot of
time
in getting presentations and reviewing
spreadsheets
you're blocking up the wrong tree
that's the that's the effect not the
course
so just get out there on the factory
floor
get out there in the stores talk to
customers
think about what what would what would
you love to have oh and you know
sometimes i think
you know and i've had this conversation
that entails a few times where it's like
we're trying to think okay we don't make
it
at times like we don't love this product
but we think others will love it
you know that's not really how it works
if you don't love it don't expect others
will either
also if you want to have more self
belief and more self confidence i've
created a special
free program where every day for the
next 254 days i will send you
an unlisted video to help you boost your
self-belief and self-confidence the link
to join for free
is in the description below if
everything has to work in two to three
years
then that limits what you can do now
fear is a really powerful thing
but when you surrender and say i'm not
scared of
fear it's unbelievably liberating
i've always been passionate some people
thought you know
it's it's more ocd than anything else
lesson number four
be aware of your mortality with jessie
itzler at one point i think you were
writing the
number of days you had on your wrist or
something like that i stopped doing that
why'd you stop i'm curious um i'm just
so aware of it now
you know um uh it was starting to freak
my wife out a little bit
uh it's a little depressing but for me
it's not depressing
it's like you know i think people's
relationship with time we talk about
relationships with humans
how's your relationship with your kids
how your relationship with your wife you
know your dad or your parents
but we never talk about a relationship
with money and time
and the relation your relationship with
time is such a key component
of your life because when you get caught
in a routine
time goes so quickly when you understand
that there are maybe only 28 summers
left and
if you want to truly you know get as
much out of experientially out of life
it just creates a tremendous amount of
urgency
so uh and the fear goes away because
you're like
and nobody on the planet like everybody
no one's gonna be here in a hundred
years do i care what
he thinks that like he's not we're not
going to be here in 100 years so why
would i take the chance
and it's just i don't know it's just so
i stopped writing it
because i'm so aware of it there's not a
day that goes by when my head hits the
pillow
where i don't say to myself like you
know did i maximize the day
and am i and you know am i aware of
my mortality and it might sound
depressing but it's it's not for me
it's um it's thrilling it's thrilling
so how is turning 50 affecting the way
that you think i'm super curious
it's just realizing that like it went so
fast and realizing that there's so much
that i want to do
and being aware that your 70s are a
different decade than your 40s and 50s
then you have 20 years left
and when you really put it in
perspective of
how many weekends there are you know
it's only 52 weekends and
you start to look at it like that you're
like i'm gonna be 80 in 30 years
scary you know i got kids it's scary
because there's a lot i want to do
i feel like i haven't done anything
compared to what i what i want to do
and the opportunities so
you know it just how do you manage your
time i never thought like that
i'm thought i'm gonna live forever and
um you know i'm bulletproof and all that
stuff and i'm not
and when you turn 50 happens friends get
sick
you know let me give you an example of
of just how it's affected me and how
even the monastery and this whole notion
of time which we've been talking it's
been a theme of this conversation
but like um are your parents alive yeah
how old are your parents if you don't
mind
70. okay and where do they live in
different parts of washington state okay
did you see him yeah
pretty often once to three times a year
okay so let's say they live to be 78
which is the
i hope they don't well let's say that
they live to the average age
so you see them one you said once to
three times yeah okay
no you don't it means you're going to
see him 16 if you see him twice a year
you can see him 16 more times
when you look at it that way you're like
what
you don't have eight years with them you
have 16
times with them and that's the shift
in my life and that's the way i look at
things
that's a fundamental shift in the way
that i looked at
situations six months ago and
it's created urgency it's created um
a need to just like not put stuff off
and to recognize like
what's on your list of things that you
want to do lesson number five
empower others with jeff bezos what i
want to achieve with blue origin
is to build the heavy lifting
infrastructure that allows for
the kind of dynamic entrepreneurial
explosion of thousands of companies in
space
that i have witnessed over the last 21
years on the internet
so when i think about the founding of
amazon.com
it it only could work so it will take
you back
to 1995 july 1995 we open our doors
and this is a 10 person company i'm
driving the packages to the post office
myself
and we had we were sitting on a bunch of
heavy lifting infrastructure
otherwise a tiny company could never
have started amazon.com you couldn't do
it
for example there was already a gigantic
logistics network
called the us postal service and ups and
fedex
that would have been tens of billions
actually hundreds of billions of dollars
of capital that you would have had to
have laid out if you had to
build a logistics network we didn't have
to do that it existed that heavy lifting
was already done
um the the the internet itself
was sitting on top of at that time
uh the long distance phone network again
tens of billions hundreds of billions of
dollars of capital put in place for long
distance phone calls
but repurposed for the internet um
payment system
there was already a payment system we
didn't have to do that it was called the
credit card and it had been initially
put in place for travelers
and so on and so on and you can go
through and what we were able to do
is take all of that heavy lifting
infrastructure
and kind of reassemble it in a new way
and
do something new and inventive with it
and that's
one lens through which you can view the
founding of amazon.com
in space today that is impossible on the
internet today
you know two kids in their dorm room can
reinvent an industry
that's how how uh how it could because
you don't you the heavy lifting
infrastructure is in place
for that today two kids in their dorm
room can't do anything interesting in
space
you know you could build a cubesat
there's not that much interesting about
cubesats
and the um it'll be that may change but
right now there's just
you need there are certain laws of
physics and certain things you need
size for and things need to be big we
need to be able to put big things in
space
at low cost and so if i'm 80 years old
and i can say to myself
that blue origin did the heavy lifting
you know kind of i'm using my amazon
winnings to
do a new piece of heavy lifting
infrastructure
um uh which is low-cost
access to space vehicles have to be
reusable you can't throw them away throw
away space vehicles every time you're
never going to lower the cost
so we're trying to lower the price of
admission into space
so that thousands of entrepreneurs can
then do amazing surprising things nobody
in 1995 that predicted
snapchat you know it's like i can't
predict for you
what amazing entrepreneurs brilliant
amazing entrepreneurs will do
in space but i know if i give them low
cost
access to space some brilliant
you know 22 year old is going to figure
it out it's one of those things about
what companies get sustainable it's
those that provide
platforms upon which others can build if
you amazon
empower others empower others to do
things
so aws is like that kindle direct
publishing is like that
our third-party selling business is like
that fulfillment by amazon is like that
every time you figure out some way of
providing tools and services that
empower
other people to deploy their creativity
you're really onto something
rule number six find something you love
with mark cuban
the type of person you are that you know
kind of points to the things you're good
at
are you 12 you're not going to know are
you 16 you're not going to know
if you're 18 maybe if you have a special
talent
yeah right you know you can throw a
baseball 100 miles an hour
you can sing and your voice is
incredible you know you're you know a
concert pianist you're a chess
grandmaster
if you have a specific skill set or
talent that just immediately propels you
to the top yeah you want to follow that
yeah but i remember having a list i
still have it when i graduated from
college i was getting ready to graduate
and all the different industries that i
thought i might want to partake in
when you find something you're good at
yeah go for it
i was never really into technology when
i was a kid
but then as i got a job that used it i
found out i was good at it
and once i found out i was good at it
then it became a lot more fun yeah you
know when you're good at something it's
almost always fun
yeah and once it was fun and i combined
that with you know my business skills
then i saw okay i know how to make money
at this stuff because i know how to sell
now i know tech that gives me something
i love to do and so
you know what i tell people the key is
find something you love to do and be
great at it
yeah because once you do that it's all
gravy for me and lesson number seven the
last one before very special bonus clip
is share your feelings with john paul de
jouria
i have had before co-partners in some
businesses i've tried
and not as good as my partner paul
mitchell but in other businesses
and they didn't turn out to be what i
thought they would be so if you have a
partner
one you've got to be friendly to one
another you also have to have your
boundaries where okay i live my life you
live your life we can't live it all
together we're together
we have a certain goal now if you do
have i call it a challenge opposed to a
problem
the best way to address it is not do it
for example aggressively
it was don't attack on it instead it's
much easier to say
well you know liz uh you're a wonderful
person we've done some really great
business together
but with all due respect when i came in
here i had a great idea wanted to tell
you
and you kept on cutting me off and it
made me feel bad liz you know as well it
just made me feel bad
and i know you'd like to hear it i just
wanted to share that with you
you share your feelings with the person
if they have an idea you don't think
it's any good you can say you know
that's
that that's a great idea i could
appreciate where you're coming from
always validate the person
however can we look at this a little
differently maybe we can enhance it and
build upon it
and you come in with your two cents
always respect the other person
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the question of the
day i want to know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video
and what is your specific plan of action
for the next
week when you just watch a video and get
motivated by it you have a 35
chance of following through but when you
get motivated and then create a specific
plan of action you have a 91 chance of
following through
that's what we do here believe nation we
get motivated but then we do
something about it and when you commit
to other people you increase your
chances even further of following
through
so what was your biggest takeaway from
this video
and then what is your plan of action
around for this week
put it down in the comments below
because i want to celebrate
you what are you most grateful for in
your life recently
my children that's easy yeah my four
children
i think every mom has to say that right
or it's just i mean it's true it's
really how i feel
um i'm also really grateful for being a
woman
born in the right country at the right
time i had nothing to do with that and
i'm very grateful
and i wake up all the time thinking of
that you know my mom
we're only 21 difference in age 21 years
my mom
her choices were so much more limited
and what was expected of her or what her
opportunities were
so i mean if you think about how long
we've been on the planet some people
think a couple thousand years some
people think a couple million
anyway it's a long time and by just 20
years
in the right country i feel like i
i was born and had the opportunity for
spanx yeah you know to fulfill a
potential or something inside of me as a
woman that
was in me and so i'm grateful for that
[Music]
if you want seven more lessons from how
billionaires think check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe
and i'll see you there by far the best
investment you can make is in yourself
if you have a good dream if you have a
plan
to making things making progress things
will happen